What do Maria,
the first of Portugal,
King Charles,
the sixth of friends and colleagues you love Rome all have in common besides
being,
you know,
rulers.
They were all pretty much crazy.
King Charles the six for example,
thought that he was made of glass.
Caligula Rome,
let's commanded his guards to throw on large section of the arena spectators
into the lion's pit because he got bored.
And Maria,
the first in later life Corinda thought she was being chased by devils.
But what are the origins of the word?
Crazy.
Crazy is at an illogical route.
Seems somewhat unclear,
but I likely origin comes from the old French word [inaudible] itself,
a borrowing from old Norse [inaudible] who's modern form and cause a like the
older form means to break shattered or crushed or cracked,
made its way into middle English as a craze.
Then through a process called [inaudible] cysts that were lost.
Its initial a,
a Ferris's simply refers to the loss of one or more sounds at the beginning of a
word,
especially in the case of unstressed vowels.
Given the fact that the craze part,
the word,
a craze forms the stressed syllable,
the unstressed syllable a dropped off in casual speech,
a craze became craze to understand how this could happen.
Try saying the following several times quickly,
I'm going to a crazy,
I'm going to crazy you.
I'm going to craze you.
I'm going to crazy.
You see what I mean?
But the evas version of the word was a verb and it wasn't until around the end
of the 16th century that we begin to see the word crop up as a noun as well.
And this new noun form pronounced the same as the verb referred to a breach
crack or flaw.
Around that same time,
cray started to be used as an adjective as well with the addition of the
derivational subjects.
Why which added the meaning of having the qualities of and thus having the
qualities of a breach or crack or full of cracks was the original meaning of the
modern English word crazy,
which was used to as fried objects such as buildings are shifts that were
cracked,
broken down,
shaky or unsound.
Shortly thereafter,
we started to use the word to describe people who were of an unsound or cracked
mine.
In other words,
insane people.
So although we don't often think about the origins of the word crazy,
it actually has a lot in common with another idiom for an insane person cracked
as in the phrase,
I think he's finally cracked.
Ah.
So that's how crazy took his place to become one of the most common words for an
insane person.
Surpassing even more modern words such as nuts and bananas,
but crazy hasn't stopped there.
And that is taken on even more meetings throughout the years.
I can be crazy for a girl like one hit wonders,
Evan and Jared,
which means I'm in moderately infatuated with her.
I can be crazy about star wars,
suggesting that I'm obsessed with it though.
Still quite sane.
So,
uh,
who's your favorite Jetta?
I,
I prefer the more obscure jet.
I like the hot,
and I can say that was a crazy dream,
which could suggest that my dream had elements of insanity,
but most likely means that I had a or strange dream and it can be used.
And even more situations like in crazy bread,
which I just think means surprisingly delicious bread.
Until next time I'm going to go back in time and watch King Charles think he's
glass.
Did that sound too crazy?